Excellent job so far.
I really hope you're excited about the new tricks that you've learned.
For this quiz, I want you to use the .each method to add the number of
characters held inside these p tags to the end of them.
In other words, a number should appear at the end of
the p tag indicating the number of characters inside it.
The .each method let's you iterate through a jQuery collection and
run a function, like so, against each DOM element.
It's kind of like a super awesome for loop that iterates over your elements.
I'll give you a hint.
If you want to use any of the jQuery methods on a DOM element
within the function that you pass in, you'll need
to use the $(this) selector to get that current element within your loop.
Without reselecting using the jQuery object, the keyword this simply refers to
the DOM element itself without all of jQuery's additional functionality.
For instance, $(this).text inside of an each loop will
return the text of each element as each iterates through the jQuery collection.
Take a look at the documentation for .each and add some numbers to your page.